[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for March
22nd 2019 I'm Megan Cantwell in this
week's show I talked to Paul Busan about
the feasibility of mining valuable
metals in the deep sea and I also speak
with Seiji Sugita
about Hayabusa to a sample return
mission to the asteroid yuku over 180
million miles from Earth you've probably
seen photos of the otherworldly
creatures that reside at the bottom of
the ocean but there are more than just
amazing organisms down there there's
also an opportunity for profit
I'm here with staff writer Paul Busan to
talk about an expedition to better
understand these treasures hey Paul
hello what is the treasure at the bottom
of the ocean there are a few different
kinds but really it's these rare metals
that are often produced on land as a
byproduct of more traditional metals
like copper but these are things like
cobalt that are you know used in
batteries and phones and they're found
in these polymetallic nodules on the
seafloor how big are these nodules a
potato size everyone says they're potato
sized not like not like easy to bite
into potatoes bigger potatoes right
seems pretty substantial yeah fairly
substantial potatoes so where exactly
are these nodules found in the ocean
they're found in all the oceans research
has shown but they're particularly found
in these regions where you have deep
abyssal Plains you know down four
kilometers this particular zone of
interest is between Hawaii and Mexico
where are you we're expecting deep sea
mine to potentially start at some point
and they're usually caused by enough
life being at the surface that that
carbon gets down to the sea Florida
prime some of the reactions that cause
these metals to leach out onto little
things like shark's teeth they're also
microbes that settle on these nodules
are there things that researchers can
learn from that there are probably
microbes involved in kind of the
formation they have they power the
chemical reactions that allowed the
oxygen-rich conditions that cause these
to form and then also you have corals
and other things that live specifically
on the nodules and most
are new to science when they're pulled
up because these are regions that have
not really been explored that much
they're part of the ecosystem it's not
like it's just not a hair net around it
I mean like everywhere on earth wherever
we look there is life how big is the
collector that's set to potentially
vacuum these nodules so this is a pre
prototype so it's not a full-size
collector but despite that it's the size
of maybe about a school bus so you know
it's it's big already they're not
sending these nodules back up to the
surface this time they're just doing a
small-scale test to look at the
environmental impacts and you know see
if this actually works that they're able
to suck these nodules up and they stick
them in a hopper dump them back out on
the sea they're not actually looking at
the nodules this time but who is the
group that's orchestrating this research
to see what the environmental impact is
and how are they going about it you have
this Belgian dredging company that is
doing this trial they're collaborating
with a independent group of European
scientists funded by Europe that are
taking out another ship and they're
going to be looking at the collector
that's what's called as it operates in
these two small regions and they'll be
have this array of sensors on autonomous
vehicles these you know little kind of
torpedo looking things a remotely
operated vehicle and a bunch of other
platforms that will monitor everything
that goes down what are they hoping to
learn so the big question in particular
is about the plume so the the silt and
sediment that gets stirred up as the
collector goes these realms is some of
the clearest water in the ocean because
the the sediment rates are so low that's
part of why the nodules can form and
once you have this collector going
through it might stir up the silt and
dump a bunch of it and you know a
millimeter or centimeter on these
life-forms they're unused to that kind
of accumulation so the question is how
far is that silt spread there's very
little data right now so this will
provide that data how long is this
expedition lasting and when will there
be some results to see what the impact
of this mining was on the environment so
it's going on this April from pretty
much all of April the actual trials will
take place in two sites probably over a
period of a little over a week in each
one and the German scientists are
completely independent they're going to
be releasing all their data
publicly they're gonna have their first
whack at it so I'm not sure the exact
timetable of when they will publish
those results I imagine being within the
next year you'll start seeing bits and
pieces coming out deep-sea mining has
been a thought for a while but why is it
that it's actually gaining traction now
are we running out of some of these
metals a lot of people don't love where
how their mine on land you know often
it's in rainforest and often bad
conditions in Democratic Republic of the
Congo or other elsewhere the technology
has gotten better so it's becoming
somewhat more feasible in the demand for
these metals particularly cobalt people
aren't projecting that to go away at all
because renewable power in particular
that needs a lot of cobalt if you're
gonna get off oil you might need more of
these metals that's a pitch the industry
is making okay and this isn't the first
expedition right to kind of study what
the environmental impacts might be the
kind of interest in this has waxed and
waned right since the 60s people in the
past have done these kind of simulated
trials where they know dredge at the
bottom of a sea floor they don't have
the kind of the technology we have to
really monitor it that well that's been
more looking at long term impacts so you
want these sites is off Peru that they
did in late 1980s researchers returned
there about three years ago three and a
half years ago and found these tracks
looked fresh like they had been made the
day before just showing how long this
ecosystem takes to bounce back from
disturbance what exactly do we know
about the deep-sea environments over I
mean so little of it has been explored
yeah you know the things that really get
a lot of attention are things like
hydrothermal events that you know how
are kind of rich with life and these
kind of charismatic creatures so these
natural realms mean it's expensive to
get down there it just hasn't been much
opportunity now that you have this
interest it's prompting a lot of
scientific research believe us the Moore
Foundation funded another survey into
the place called the cleric Clarion
Clipperton zone between Hawaii and
Mexico to look at the deep sea life
there and there's fine a host of kind of
strange
interesting creatures that I think in
the East one survey found 70 percent of
them were new to science so a lot could
be lost potentially potentially but
these are big we're losing a lot now
it's a tough call right if the earth had
never been mined and you were choosing
between mining rainforest or mining
these environments on the seafloor it's
it's not the easiest call it's a complex
decision so scientists really they're
trying to be pragmatic and how they
approach this and think if this is going
to happen let's you know try and
understand the impacts try to make sure
we are protecting regions and now this
is really the first extractive industry
to come about with environmental
concerns factoring in from the start so
since the UN is governing this there's
some hope that they'll be done somewhat
responsibly and this is an international
water so they still have to figure out
who would even be allowed to mine here
right yeah so the UN has this body
called the International seabed
authority that governs the international
waters exploitation and they're still
drafting rules for exploitation probably
won't happen for another few years this
expedition will probably go into
informing those rules the mining isn't
gonna happen for a while then yeah I
mean most projections seem to be late
next decade but you never know thanks so
much Paul yeah thank you stay tuned for
my interview with Seiji Sugita about
what his team has learned so far from
Hayabusa to
[Music]
in 2014 Hayabusa 2 was launched and in
June of 2018 it reached its target the
asteroid dukkha which is located between
Earth and Mars
just last month Hayabusa 2 collected a
sample of the asteroid
I'm here with Seiji Sugita to talk about
what his team has learned from the
mission so far and what they hope to
understand about the asteroid once the
sample returns to earth thanks for
joining me Seiji thank you and it's
really a great pleasure to be here first
I want to talk a little bit about the
fact that this is Hayabusa 2 what
happened on the first expedition with
just Hayabusa the original Hayabusa went
to s type asteroid it's a world without
water or hydrous mineral we had a little
problem here and there but we finally
made it back to the earth with small
pieces of rock and almost like a dust
particles over asteroid Itokawa that
really demonstrated the capability of
jackson the engineers that we can do a
round-trip to a small asteroid and bring
that sample to the earth the first
Hayabusa was with what you said was an S
type asteroid and Hayabusa twos
expedition is to you goo which is a
c-type asteroid could you talk about
what that means and why you specifically
chose this type of asteroid c-type
asteroid the C stands for carbon c-type
asteroid is considered to be carbon
because the color is very black and an
estimated to have a lot of water
organics and carbon bearing material
those are ingredients for life if it
really gets supply to the surface of
planetary bodies such as Earth Mars
that's why c-type asteroid is far more
interesting to scientists to explore one
of the main goals of the mission is to
return a sample from this asteroid home
and although it's not going to be back
for a while what kind of tests do you
hope to run and understand about the
asteroid once the sample does come back
there are series of questions
relax address the content of water and
in the kinds of organics and those were
isotopic characterizations of water
organic molecules by identifying the
isotopic composition we can probably
identify where in the solar system or
what kind of condition of us location
within the solar system those materials
are coming from those are very important
pieces of information for understanding
the evolution of solar system or the
supply mechanisms of organics of water
in a solar system to earth and other
planted bodies
initially the plan was to get three
samples from this asteroid but that may
not be the case now the first touchdown
was so difficult because there the
surface are--you as covered over there
all kinds of a different large boulders
and it was very difficult to find a good
location and then the engineers had to
really upgrade and improve the technique
to make a really high precision keen
point touchdown but that happened so
that consumed a lot of time so most
likely reduced down to two touchdowns in
on two different locations so the
touchdown was successful then but you
don't know yet how much of the sample
you got from the asteroid we don't have
a mechanism to measure the amount of
asteroid or the samples on our
spacecraft however I'm a irresponsible
dreaming scientist that we have a very
hopeful finding with a lot of pebbles on
fragments coming out of the touchdown
sites those must have got into the
sampler horn and in the sample capsule
mechanisms Hayabusa 2 still has a long
journey home but that doesn't mean that
you haven't learned things already since
it's been surveying the asteroid for a
couple of months and your team has three
papers coming out in science that talk a
little bit about what you've learned so
far several series of findings we made
the first one it has a shape very close
to the spinning top it probably was
formed when V goo was spitting at a much
faster spinning rate than now so that
really shows that this type of a small
asteroid may change its spinning state
why often wha
rapidly we don't know the profound
implication for this but it's a very
important piece of information and also
it's a basis of understanding this type
of asteroid so that's number one another
important finding was its bulk density
it turns out to be very light it's only
one point two grams per cubic
centimeters making a one point two grams
per CC requires a lot of ports so there
the poor volume ratio is as high as 50
percent so half of the other vigor is a
void this really is possible only if bu
is a so-called a rubble pile the jumble
of all kinds of a fragments and then
they're very just randomly pack loosely
together with its gravity that's the
only way we can think of to make 1.2
grams per CC you were also able to study
the surface composition of the asteroid
as well right that's right as for the
composition we found a couple pieces of
very important information hydrated
mineral the mineral that has reacted
with the liquid water those material we
thought was quite abundant on the
surface of the our measurement has shown
that amount of hydrated minerals is not
as abundant as we were thinking so the
hydrated minerals were less abundant
than you thought they'd be does this
provide any clues for how you might have
formed the original Ferriero idea is
that those asteroids are created in a
very low temperature location or solar
system then that automatically retains a
lot of water or water bearing minerals
and then when they hit slanted bodies
such as earth we will have a lot of
supply of water or other so-called
volatile elements like organics and
carbon bearing molecules but now after
looking at the moderately dehydrated
asteroid the parent body processes
they're sitting between the accretion
and then a final evolution
of the asteroid changes the a degree or
the amount of water and other volatiles
in a course of evolution so even if
those asteroid it's a parent body
accreted in a cold place
if the evolution subsequent evolution
within the parent body really lose those
of all house we don't necessarily
receive too much water or organics in a
solar system so there's one more
important process that really controls
the amount of life's ingredient
available on a large part a surfaces
speaking of how the asteroid form does
the color give you any insight about
that process our camera can take a
distribution of a different colors of
Regal and in a color really tells us
about the difference in mineralogical
variation our reservation showed that
the material on the surface of Regal is
quite homogeneous individual particles
or boulders of blue goo are very similar
to each other so parent body of a review
must be quite homogeneous and in the
only way we can think of to make the
homogeneity of a really good parent body
is a radiogenic heating in its current
body radiogenic heating is heating due
to the decay of radioactive isotopes
those isotopes breaks down and then in
the process of a decay he generates heat
subsequently dehydration's and other
more metamorphosed happens as opposed to
impact generated heat and other
mechanisms the other homogeneity or
heterogeneity over a surface can
constrain the process that must have
happening in a parent body of you do you
have an idea of when dugu's parent body
might have formed because parent body
was formed in the early evolution of
solar system or at the same time as the
adaptive system in the solar system
there's currently another sample return
mission happening from NASA
osiris-rex could you talk about how your
study
compliments NASA's expedition there are
a lot of surprising things we learn by
comparing osiris-rex results on the
types a to result
osiris-rex is a studying a little
smaller sized asteroid called a B'nai
venom is another top shape fast spinning
asteroid and its color is very black
very similar to ryu
it's probably have a lot of carbon like
bigger the rubble pile nature is also
they're smaller but the water abundance
of Benner it's so much more than reason
so there are a lot of similarity and
however somehow water abundance is quite
different and even their parent bodies
may be the same so how can we really
make such contrasting bodies out of a
such a similarity when we find out why
there's such a difference that would
really place a very important constraint
only really great answer can resolve
this problem so I think we have a very
important piece of information to work
on for years and possibly not hopefully
not dgaede but the many years of a time
thank you so much thank you
Seiji Sugita is a professor at the
University of Tokyo in the Department of
Earth and Planetary Science and
principal investigator of the optical
navigation camera of Hayabusa 2 you can
find a link to his research at science
bag org slash podcasts
and that concludes this edition of the
science podcast if you have any comments
or suggestions for the show write to us
at science podcast at AAA SOR G you can
subscribe to the show anywhere you get
your podcasts or become listed on the
science website that science Magdeburg
slash podcasts to place an ad on the
science podcast contact mid-roll calm
this show is produced by Meghan Cantwell
and Sarah Crespi and edited by Potter
chain Jeffrey cook composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and its
publisher triple-a s thanks for joining
us